economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está lista en el estudio daniela
blandón daniela ya jueves ya casi
acabando la semana y vamos a empezar
hablando entonces de la economía
española porque hay escasez de
trabajadores porque dan hola aragón muy
buenos días viernes para mí porque
mañana no hay dios mío la vamos a
extrañar pero bueno seguramente viene
luís méndez que también lo queremos aquí
en este estudio el largo casi pues de
raúl hablemos de españa mire cuando en
2008 estalló una crisis inmobiliaria de
vivienda y de construcción
desaparecieron 18 millones de empleos y
también muchas obras que se estaban
realizando en ese momento ahora el país
necesita esos empleados de vuelta al
menos si quiere recibir dinero del fondo
de recuperación europea pero hay una
escasez de mano de obra de mano de obra
sin precedentes de al menos medio millón
de esos empleados muchos de los cuales
se refugiaron en el sector hotelero en
ese momento es lo que se necesita son
personal cualificado se necesita
personal cualificado albañiles se
necesita electricista sanidad fontaneros
y es urgente pues ahora mismo viene unos
fondos europeos y estamos hablando desde
la patronal se está diciendo y desde
bueno desde la fundación laboral
aproximadamente unos 700 mil puestos de
trabajo yo no sé si valorar tantos o no
pero una cantidad de gente sí pero es
así personal formado danny y le pregunté
entonces cómo se explica que faltan
trabajadores con una tasa de desempleo
tan alta raúl pues en el caso de los
jóvenes se estima que uno de cada tres
hoy no tienen trabajo en ese país
europeo nada las tasas más altas pero
tampoco quieren emplearse en la
construcción que apenas el 11 por ciento
de ellos tiene trabajo en este sector
como lo escuchamos a continuación ahora
mismo a la gente joven española en vista
de los sueldos que dan y de lo que hiló
y lo difícil que es pues no le atrae
este mundo entonces nos toca pues lo que
decía antes uno pagar más y de otra
parte también pues está traer a la
inmigración y darles estos puestos pero
no sólo darle estos puestos también hay
que formarles y enseñarles y el pasado
2021 fue el año de la recuperación
verso internacional que tanto se
recuperó claro pues no todo es malo
ahora dormiré si en 2020 que fue el peor
año de la pandemia el comercio
internacional había caído un 9% en el
2021 pues ya tuvo una buena recuperación
a pesar de la crisis en la cadena de
suministros la cifra llegó a 28 5
billones de dólares en 2021 una cuarta
parte más de lo que había registrado el
año anterior o sea 25 por ciento de
crecimiento también un 13% más que antes
de la pandemia según naciones unidas las
razones son entre otras las alzas en los
precios de las materias primas también
el levantamiento de las restricciones
sanitarias y una demanda renovada de
bienes y servicios impulsada por las
ayudas gubernamentales el país que más
creció en exportaciones fue
evidentemente raúl chino y danny también
una de las industrias insignias de
paraguay está reduciendo su producción
por culpa de la sequía el cambio
climático pues también está a la vuelta
de la esquina mejor dicho ya está con
nosotros claro raúl y sabía usted que
ese país sudamericano es el portador
mundial de soja de quién estamos
hablando estamos hablando de paraguas y
pues mire
este país a pesar de que es el cuarto
exportador mundial se enfrenta a su peor
cosecha en una década con una caída
prevista de la producción a la mitad
desde los 10 millones de toneladas de la
campaña anterior esto llevaría a la
industria de la trituración a quedarse
sin grano para procesar a mediados de
año la cámara paraguaya de procesadores
de hoy la gente oleaginosas y cereales
explica que todo se debe a la extrema
sequía que ha azotado el país desde
finales del año pasado y que también ha
dañado el rendimiento de los cultivos
uno de los problemas ha sido raúl en la
navegación de la vía fluvial y paraguay
paraná que eleva los costos de
transporte de los granos procesados para
la exportación
que este país no tiene salida al mar el
clima también está afectando a su vecino
argentina que es el principal exportador
mundial de soja procesada bueno el
cambio climático haciendo estragos o
mejor dicho nosotros los humanos daniel
indicadores
y los mercados del mundo dejaron
parcialmente de lado ucrania para operar
mixtos y concentrarse en las minutas de
la reserva federal en europa también hay
resultados dispares después de que las
minutas que no son más que un documento
en el que la fed plasma sus ideas sobre
la más reciente reunión de junta
directiva pues dijera que se enfocarán
en la inflación de una manera más
decisiva esto quiere decir básicamente
que hay un posible aumento de tasas
cifra el día ya para finalizar esta
única crónica de hoy
3,8 por ciento aumentó el gasto en las
tiendas minoristas de eeuu en enero
frente a diciembre y esto lo que
demuestra raúl es que los consumidores
siguientes haciendo la alta inflación
que en apenas un año se disparó en más
del 7% y es que ese aumento se dio no
tanto porque hay precios más altos sino
porque hay mayores compras vea la gente
sigue siendo la gente sigue gastando la
platica daniela gracias entonces por
toda la información económica pasamos
ahora a ver nuestro reportaje del día